brutto stronzo assaggia il mio culo
mica è curata in faccia di quelle
potenti madonna che botta è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sua allora
ma porca [ __ ] evergreen si fa fi poco
spacca la zia perché non sei nessuno
vabbè ragazzi in poche parole siamo su
che sarebbe un videogioco nel quale ci
sono conigli e cattivi con il
praticamente ragazzi io sono un coniglio
un coniglio su due gambe che corre come
non so cosa deve deve minare gli altri
con conigli credo che siano conigli
geneticamente modificati perché non mi
spiego sta cosa
video di te che mi ha fatto male accusa
non l'ho fatto apposta è orientato
questi sì si massacrano sangue
senti eh io io io volevo soltanto
stringerti la mano da amico scusa vabbè
comunque piacere e poi vigente ma io io
e lui contro di te ok allora pezzo di
merda giorno sono morto sono morto sono
morto ha vinto lui era uno contro 2 ha
vinto lui non si sa come visto fra la
ragazza devo riuscire a fare una cosa
epica devo farmene fuori 21 nicchia che
calcio nelle palle potente mai così vai
così vai così vai così uno lo schifo lo
schifo lo schifo ancora è un calcio in
faccia ma sono ancora vivo sono ancora
vivo ce la posso fare ma posso fare che
cosa può tutto mente piga no ma che
cazzo fatto che cosa che ho fermato il
tecnico come faccio a fermare se
confermare il tempo scriva lo scriva 00
o che per madonna madonna
mou non ha
porca [ __ ] che cosa epica ragazzini
manca 1 ok come non detto vabbè ci ho
provato ragazzi e uno scontro epocale
abbiate pazienza ma io riesco a fermare
il tempo ed è una cosa che mi gasa
troppo devo riuscire su cup dove cilea a
buttarlo giù così tifosi mamma mia mamma
mia che scontro tra titani che devo devo
riuscire dove di questo lo vedi qui si
alza come cazzo fa c'è un calcio in
faccia così s rialzato non ci posso
credere
avevo richiesto un massaggio alla
schiena ma non è proprio questo che
intendevo vediamo di chiarire la
faccenda come due vari signori brutto
stronzo
queste cose sono è troppo epiche mi
sembra di giocare a matrix madonna in
pugno in faccia calci in testa ed enza
fave non sarà che come cazzo fatto non
chiedetemelo brutto stronzo assaggia il
mio culo vice che è curata in faccia di
quelle potenti madonna che botta ti
senti 6 far trovare i [ __ ]
no è bravo perché cazzo qua madonna si
sta si sta spiazzi qando al muro in una
maniera mai vista è caduto in piedi sia
caduto in piedi perché voglio provare a
fare una cosa pica che non so se vi
riesce
ok ok ok sta riuscendo sta riuscendo sta
riuscendo sta riuscendo
allora signori è il momento di
concludere come dei veri uomini d'affari
a calci in faccia grande convinzione la
mossa incredibile ancora lui ancora lui
ancora lui
[Applauso]
vabbè questa ho fatto una cosa che non
mi riuscirà mai più nella storia
non ho neanche idea di come ho fatto gli
è rimasta ancora il segno a quello rosa
ho bisogno questo è un calcio in culo
come si deve altro che quelli che mi dà
la mia mamma era ancora peggio devo
riuscire fermi un attimo fermi un attimo
luca luca perché tu comune mortale osi
sfidare me perché ragazza è il coniglio
ninja il suo movimento e leggenda la sua
maestra è quella inciampato a caso cosa
questo ma come cazzo è morto
diamogli una mano poveri assenti siede
vittoria ti dai [ __ ] perché qua sto
pulendo io e devi togliti dalle palle
ancora non hai capito madonna mia che
chi è professionista ragazzi che mosse
di comfort lei voglio provare a fare un
attacco etico ma non so se mi riesce
ok perfetto perché la sorpresa con lui
che era già morto vabbè la gara che a
prendermela con i più con i morti è nel
mio stile che poi ancora lui capì che
calcia in mano una spada una spaccio una
squadra che più grossa del mio corpo c'è
una cosa incredibile ma fa male sa cosa
c'è insomma spari di gomma vero sono
spalle sono spagna cazzo visto che non è
proprio di gomma stai lontano da me è la
mannaia dello chef tony devo tipo
sfidare sto tizio ok ok
mio nonno che cosa ho schivato non ci
posso credere sì sì ho vinto io è una
cosa che adesso ci abbiamo il coltellino
in realtà non è proprio un coltellino
perché è una roba tanto però in
confronto a quello di prima è veramente
piccolo no non lo accetto attento che ti
dirà testata di quelle poté mamma mia
che parco cioè parkour di potenza e poi
riesco anche magari a farlo fuori tipo
senza ok ok ok ok ok ok
mi piace botta ma da oltre mi sa che
sono morti perfetto con il più potente
freestyler della storia e mi sono tipo
spiaccicato a terra come non so cosa
ragazzi e bellissimo mi spiace che a
terra che cazzo fa ragazzi sarà il
duello più emozionanti di sempre e tela
vecchi in faccia brutto stronzo boom da
assaggia il mio culo che cazzo fa a
perfetto l'ho beccato non si sa con
quali poteri mistici
però però vinto e va bene così affronta
la realtà brutto stronzo affrontavi
coniglio non è un insulto sei proprio un
coniglio no guarda che pezzi di hai
rotto ma allora aspetta un attimo che
migliore devo dare in testa di santa
ragione tipo adesso ma perché non si fa
un kart ma butt ma guarda lì che
classico ma come ha fato termico si ma
dai ma devi morire ho detto devi morire
ma come cazzo fa pararmi ste cose
sembra così impressionante suo coniglio
no no no no a bravo zio adesso hai
capito tutto
hai capito come si ragiona con fa dj e è
quello che hai capito dello grillo che
hai capito dello brutto stop vieni qui a
far vieni qui a parlarmi in faccia non è
finita finché non lo dico io
non è finita finché io io sparo raggi
dagli occhi
sa cosa mi è nuova non lo sapevo tu non
sai contro che si sta mettendo coniglio
non lo sai non lo sai non lo sa o che
forse ora lo sai io ti faccio un culo
ancora lenti blekko atti questo pezzo di
merda è volato in una ma neanche morto
perfetto se si senta mi scusi mi
dispiace che sia morto però non volevo
allora io io io ti amo volevo chiedere
la tua mano molto prima mi sembra il
momento adatto ad esso quindi vuoi
sposarmi tu o coniglio non è un insulto
ti sei un coniglio mi vuoi sposarmi ok
ha reagito subito allora facciamo così
giochiamo a se scappi ti sposo e così
almeno è infatti mi sembra che tu sia
dell'idea giu
[Applauso]
comi tradisci [ __ ] ragazzi è la cosa
che non mi è andata giù mi dispiace ma
che cazzo di posto figura è questo
ragazzino vabbè ma avete mai visto un
coniglio che rotola giù da una duna di
sabbia enorme c'è stessa cosa sfiora
l'epicità più assoluta c'è anche che
cazzo è quella roba lì c'è un buongiorno
e vika casa sua questa no scherzavo
scherzavo non c'è bisogno di alterarsi
aiuto di stupro nel deserto perfetto non
è proprio normale sta cosa
no no sono morto da senti io ciò stia
attacchi di svenimento abbi pazienza non
salire lo sarebbe perfetta dal tu qua
non ci sei arrivare brutto stronzo
quindi evita fatemi entrare c'è uno
stupratore nel deserto ragazzi uno
scontro epico tra le dune mai visto
spero rifare lo aspettate un attimo che
questo tizio vuole sopranino non ha
capito con chi ha a che fare
tu lo sai chi sono io frutto strozzo con
le orecchie troppo grosse sono fa vj
brutto coniglio
oddio e la velista mossa e la sai la
prossima dove te la faccio
hai capito brutto stronzo porca [ __ ]
che potenza cia me la sono presa io nel
già pranzi ma stavolta è stata una
figata abbiate pazienza
ok anche questa forse sono mica morto e
soddisfatto adesso [ __ ] linosa che
s'apre star aggredito da un coniglio
ninja ai conigli ninja sono letali
lo sanno tutti allora arrivo arrivo per
il distretto 12 se magari i calci di
tirassi però se non salti a cazzo senza
motivo bravo zio come non è bravo bravo
così
ok ok ci posso fare ciò posso fare ce la
posso fare ciò posso fare para mi sto
cazzo ok olè olè olè mango via si
madonna rega madonna negli prossimo per
la cosa la prossima cosa che faccio il
casting per matrix 4
sei stato un grande combattente e ti
ricorderemo tutti per il tuo onore vivi
per sempre o grandissimo guerriero e bra
[ __ ] a ragazzine che possono
concludere qui comunque volevo dirvi che
sto gioco qui mi piace mi piace da matti
vi giuro dato che sono abbastanza di
esperta nel senso che hanno scoperto da
pochissimo se qualcuno di voi che ci
gioca da tanto non so comunque conosce
qualche trucchetto o questo e mappa
divertente me lo dica perché era che sta
roba è una figata pazzesca franche
ragazzi se vi do è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato argomento mi piace è
sempre stato anche voi che conigli siano
dei combattenti pazzeschi lasciate mi
piace anche alla pace di facebook
ricovero nei video tratte nella
descrizione 60 iscritti scrivete quindi
ci rimettiamo in un prossimo video beh
ragazzi